Congress preparing for a new round of
relief measure Speaker Nancy Pelosi says
lawmakers might consider extending those
one-time checks from the federal
government as part of a brand-new relief
package and that will be coming up soon
watch we may have to think in terms of
some different ways to put money in
people's pockets let's see what works
what is what is operational and what
needs other attention others have
suggested a minimum and come for a
guaranteed income for people is that
worthy of attention now perhaps so let's
bring in Jonathan Swann he's of course a
national political reporter for Axios
good morning Jonathan morning yet
Republicans already raising eyebrows
about whether this is the best idea
although wasn't anticipating Nancy
Pelosi becoming maybe a member of the
yang gang we heard this back earlier in
the campaign didn't we yes I don't think
that one's gonna happen the guaranteed
minimum wage and and both the sides have
a lot of differences between the two of
them in terms of arguments about funding
for state and local governments in terms
of liability protection for businesses
there's all sorts of issues there at the
same time you've got unemployment
heading upwards and these are all
politicians some of them are up for
re-election all of them in the house are
and some in the Senate so I do
anticipate they'll reach some kind of an
agreement but at the moment they're
pretty far apart yeah Jonathan I want to
switch gears because we just got this
breaking news from the hill you've got
your ear close to the ground there as
well as the White House Steny Hoyer one
of the Democratic leaders obviously is
just announced he's switching his
decision the house is now not returning
to session next week they've consulted
with the attending physician and the
Capitol as you know the lead doctor
there they were under pressure as you
know to get back to work work on on some
of these economic measures but as you
know there's been a lot of angst behind
the scenes about whether it's a good
idea to get a big group of lawmakers
staffers lobbyists you name it back on
Capitol Hill at a time when we're still
not sure where all this is headed and
part of that is is because a lot of
these lawmakers are in the highest risk
profile actually more so in the Senate
in the house so it's interesting that
it's the house that's I suppose that run
by Democrats who are more cautious on
this but you know elderly members many
of them have some car and condition so
there has been a lot of concern about
that and as you know very well it's a
very confined space it's not now easy to
do social distancing in the capital okay
we'll watch that as we get more details
in the meantime fascinating story broken
this morning by the Wall Street Journal
about this Manhattan Project type group
that's vowing to fight the corona virus
beyond firing on all cylinders you have
this eclectic group of scientists and
billionaires one of the folks running it
out of a one-bedroom apartment in Boston
near Fenway Park tell us what you know
about this and whether people at the
White House think it could be a game
changer
well people at the White House are very
open to different opinions that are
outside of government particularly Jared
Kushner who has always been saying you
know government alone can't solve this
we need different voices so I would say
it's more receptive than a traditional
White House is to two outside voices to
unconventional voices and so you are
seeing a lot of people on the outside
having direct relationships with very
senior people Trump himself has always
sought people's opinions way outside of
government constantly he doesn't like
having the same set of inputs he likes
to have a very very broad array of
inputs and I put that in this category
well because in thinking outside the box
on something this like this may be very
important you want to consult the
government scientists like dr. Fauci and
others who are already there but maybe
bringing in business leaders scientists
and others outside the government as you
know could be an interesting element and
they're doing that and I suppose the
most important thing is that at the end
of it at the end of the day that
whatever decisions you make
evidence-based absolutely all right
let's get to you've got this HBO special
you've had this long running a series
going on HBO fascinating that as a guest
you have the New York Governor Andrew
Cuomo and he's saying something
how all this started at let's play and
we'll get you to react when we heard in
December that China had a virus problem
and China said basically it was under
control don't worry
we should have worried they wish someone
stood up and blew the bugle I would feel
better sitting here today saying I blew
the bugle about Wuhan province in
January I can't say that interesting
clip for a number of reasons one being
that as we all expect that potentially
the presidential election could be
prosecuted on the question of how is the
president handled this crisis this
crisis started in part with his
Democratic critics saying the president
should have done a lot more he should
have he should have sounded that bugle
if you will and now what a powerful
Democrat like Andrew Cuomo says I wish I
had done it when you see the video
footage of Nancy Pelosi a top Democrat
who was saying go to Chinatown early on
here when we didn't have all the facts
how do you mix all that up as we get
closer and closer to November
well Cuomo is really interesting because
I mean prepare for this interview I
really spend a lot of time looking at
the statistics and the data and it is
just shocking when you look at New York
City the death toll in New York City is
just when you compare it around the
world forget China forget the Chinese
statistics but when you compare it to
other dense global cities like Tokyo and
Japan's so when you compare it to the
country of Germany when New York has the
one of the worst death tolls in the
world so it was very striking to have
the person who leads that state be
actually quite self-critical quite
introspective but also very squarely
saying that the Chinese have a lot to
answer for and that there does actually
need to be a proper accounting of what
happened in Wuhan and what happened in
China in December and January holding
China accountable expected to be front
and center in this presidential campaign
as well Jonathan Swan appreciate all
your insights this morning thank you
thank you